das meine damen und herren hat wirklich
keiner kommen sehen trump versus beiden
das tv-duell vergangene nacht war ja
fast schon so etwas wie ein gespräch
unter erwachsenen verglichen mit der
pudel orgie beim letzten mal
wir meinen natürlich hat trotzdem am
fließband lügen rausgehauen aber eben
nicht mehr raus geschrien
man ist ja inzwischen schon mit wenig
zufrieden die deutschen tv kommentatoren
jedenfalls konnten das heute morgen kaum
fassen
vor allem präsident trump legte den
schalter um weniger aggressiv er sprach
ruhig wollte zeigen ich kann auch
höflich ich möchte darauf reagieren darf
ich danke das weiß ich zu schätzen
darf ich danke das war noch nie im leben
donald trump max giermann oder so keine
ahnung aber keine angst den alten donald
gibt es ja auch noch vor allem bei
seinen release da hetzt und schreit er
weiter für die fans und er tanzt ist
ausdrücklich kein witz bei jedem trump
auftritt wird jetzt ein ganz spezieller
song für ihn eingespielt born in the usa
hätte man nehmen können of the tiger
aber er wollte tatsächlich das hier
[Musik]
das haben nicht mal die village people
verdienen junge andererseits muss ich
zugeben er tanzt besser als ich was
leicht ist es wahnsinn
es ist wirklich wahnsinn was die korona
medikamente mit dem typen machen
obama hatte noch hope plakate aufgehängt
bei trump müsste es doch heißen
eigentlich meine es ist egal wie die
wahl ausgeht die usa werden jahre
brauchen um sich von trump zu erholen
von der spaltung von dem ganzen hass und
trotzdem ist ja immer noch im rennen in
nur sieben sekunden erklärt warum donald
trump doch noch gewinnen könnte in
deutschland hängt jeder zwang ist ein
idiot
er ist ein idiot aber sie werden ihn ja
klar
er ist ein idiot und deshalb vertritt er
nicht so ideal aber die spannendste
frage bleibt was wird trump im fall
einer niederlage machen wie weit wird er
dann gehen ja in michigan wollten rechte
milizionäre gerade die demokratische
gouverneur in gretchen widmen führen
sollte beiden in zwölf tagen siegen
fürchten manche bürgerkriegsähnliche
zustände wohl nicht zu unrecht
angesichts solcher bilder hier schwer
bewaffnete milizen ziehen durch
louisville kentucky mit automatischen
gewehren und die polizei ist unsichtbar
kann man aber erklären denn das waren ja
bewaffnete weiß
einige üben da seit jahren den
bewaffneten aufstand und trump gießt
noch öl ins feuer meine klar der mann
hat durchaus viele fans auch bei uns
selber so mundschutz zb leitet die
einzige deutsche trump miliz im
arnsberger forst im sauerland hieß es
ski was machen sie da und ist das schon
ihre komplette truppe sind sie
vollzählig hh sehr witzig natürlich
nicht so jetzt sind wir vollzählig
manfred ernsthaft wenn du warst hast
kannst du nicht die heideschule kacken
gehen welche wir verteidigen hier die
demokratie
wer sich aus seriösen russischen quellen
informiert weil trump wird nach dem
wahlbetrug er also nach dem putsch durch
den djp state beziehungsweise bill gates
und clinton obama hat kinderschänder
bande mit lady gaga ins ausland fliehen
müssen
und der kopf platzt exil nur an land in
frage
das land seiner ahnen deutsches blut der
geistes das überhaupt haben sie das
gelesen im bundesstaat michigan ist es
seit mittwoch verboten in wahllokal
waffen zu tragen eine kleine zur wahl
ist keine demokratie mehr dagegen
leisten wir hier vom sauerland aus
widerstand also sind sie so eine art
wehrsportgruppe klar
also in sachen waffen ist noch luft nach
oben
wir haben insgesamt einen aufgang und
eine alte rauchgranate also wir hatten
rauchgranate aber dann ist die manfred
vorhin beim üben ein malheur passiert
die zahlst du manfred vollidiot ihr hier
von den live stream medien in eurem
zwangsgebühren elfenbeinturm ihr müsst
endlich mal begreifen wo sein donald
trump geleistet hat und wie viele
deutsche den vergöttern was halten sie
denn von fromm
kannst du das fast immer um ich hier bin
und was für ein tier konnte sich das so
vorstellen was sie von ihm halten oder
besser präsidenten schön durch steht
euch hat er gesagt einer der besten
neben kennedy ja klar besser als kennedy
was bleibt den hängen von candy fall
noch kein berlin ihre dreckige lügner
trump der kümmert sich wenigstens um
sein volk also um weiße menschen also
beziehungsweise orangene werke fresse
jetzt starten wir unser tägliches drill
program die folgende übung hatte dazu ab
gegen die zunehmende verschulung und
westlicher gesellschaften also musik
[Musik]
ja wenn das nicht hilft selber so und
schuh
ja it-service beweise sprechen mit
jürgen wie kann ich ihnen weiterhelfen
ja haben sie mal versucht das gerät aus
und wieder einzuschalten hat nichts
gebracht verstehe
probieren sie doch mal den kanal der
heute show auf youtube zu abonnieren
genau und im zweifel wo ich auch mal den
gefällt mir -button klicken
genau ja ich bleibe in der leitung